we are asked what is the value of the
hundredth term in this sequence and the
first term is 15 then 9 and 3 the
negative 3 so let's write it like this
in a table so if we have the term just
so we have things straight and then we
have the value and then we have the
value of the term I'll do it nice little
table here so our first term we saw is
15 our second term is 9 our third term
is 3 I'm just really copying this down
but I'm making sure we associate it with
the right term and then our fourth term
our fourth term is negative 3 and they
want to ask they want us to figure out
what the hundredth term of this sequence
is going to be so let's see what's
happening here if we can discern some
type of pattern so we went from the
first term to the second term what
happened 15 to 9 it looks like we went
down by 6 it's always good to think
about just how much the numbers changed
by that's always the simplest type of
pattern so we went down by 6 we
subtracted 6 then to go from 9 to 3
well we subtracted 6 again we subtracted
6 again and then to go from 3 to
negative 3 well we we subtracted 6 again
we subtracted 6 again so it looks like
every every term you subtract 6 so the
second term is going to be 6 less than
the first term the third term is going
to be 12 minus the first term or
negative 6 subtracted twice so in the
third term you subtract negative 6 twice
in the fourth term you subtract negative
6 three times so whatever term you're
looking at you subtract negative 6 one
less than that many times let me write
this down just so notice when you your
first term you have 15 and you don't
subtract negative 6 at all or you could
say you subtract negative 6 0 times so
you could say this is 15 minus negative
6 times or let me write it the better
this way minus 0 times negative 6 that's
what that first
is right there what's the second term
this is 15 it's just we just subtracted
negative six once or you could say minus
one times six or you can say plus one
times negative six either way we're
subtracting the six once now what's
happening here this is 15 this is 15
minus 2 times negative 6 or sorry minus
2 times 6 minus 2 times 6 we're
subtracting a 6 twice what's the fourth
term this is 15 minus we're subtracting
the 3 the sixth 3 times from the 15 so
minus 3 times 6 so if you see the
pattern here when our term when we have
our fourth term we have the term minus 1
right there the fourth term we have a 3
the third term we have a 2 the second
term we have a 1 so if we had the nth
term if we just had the nth term here
what's this going to be it's going to be
15 minus you see it's going to be n
minus 1 right here right when n is 4 n
minus 1 is 3 when n is 3 and minus 1 is
2 when n is 2 and minus 1 is 1 when n is
1 n minus 1 is 0 so we're going to have
this term right here is n minus 1 so
minus n minus 1 times 6 so if you want
to figure out the hundredth term of this
sequence I didn't even have to write it
in this general term you could just look
at this pattern it's going to be and
I'll do it in pink the hundredth term in
our sequence I'll continue our table
down it's going to be what it's going to
be 15 minus 100 minus 1 which is 99
times 6 right I just followed the
pattern 1 you had a 0 here - you had a 1
here 3 at a 2 here 100 you're going to
have a 99 here so let's just calculate
what this is what's 99 times 6 so 99
times 6 actually you could do this in
your head you could say that's going to
be 6 less than 100 times 6 which
is 606 less is 594 but if you doesn't
want to do it that way you just do it
the old-fashioned way
6 times 9 is 54 carry the 5 9 times 6 or
6 times 9 is 54 54 plus 5 is 594 so this
right here is 594 and then to figure out
what 15 so we want to figure out we want
to figure out what 15 minus 594 is and
this can sometimes be confusing but the
way I always process this in my head as
I say that this is the exact same thing
as the negative of 594 minus 15 and if
you don't believe me MultiJet out this
negative sign negative 1 times 594 is-
594 negative 1 times negative 15 is
positive 15 so these two statements are
equivalent this is much easier for my
brain to understand so what's 594 minus
15 you should do it we can do this in
our head 594 minus 14 would be 580 and
then 580 minus one more would be 579 so
that right there is 579 and then we have
this negative sign sitting out there so
our 100th term in our sequence will be
negative 579